when I say streams who says i'm working
with streams right now and that's okay
if you're not that's probably I'm doing
it a little bit more towards I'm talking
about what streams are some of my work
with it and what that means in the
browser one of things i like about
having you know the opportunity and talk
together is actually not really to do
this part so much is for us to talk
later and i've got a lot of questions
about the world of JavaScript and html5
i right actually more like node and
server-side JavaScript then I do the
front end so i get opportunity to talk
with you guys I really appreciate that
so if anything up here seems interesting
you know I say it wrong and you want to
correct me you can certainly do that
afterwards we talked like I would really
like to talk if you want to do it in
public and shame me maybe do not Twitter
or you can kind of in between passive
aggressive digital version and email me
directly I'll just ignore you and press
spam so but that does go without saying
that I'm really happy here John Paul is
doing a really nice job organizing this
I mean the amount of emails of the prep
work and helping
top of this is second to none so I'm
going to use a few I'm use to terms when
I talk about street and one of them is
the word stream itself and the other is
the word buffer and sometimes it's easy
to just start diving in you're talking
about buffering and streaming and you
know I think what comes to mind for me
when I your streams is like a real
player from to thousands like that's a
stream video which isn't really hope
talking about is what's at the
fundamental level but it's the
disassociation with that I think is
important and then buffer I always
remember like when I have my CD burner
on a parallel port and I'd have buffer
underrun zor over rights or whatever it
was until I got a scuzzy zebra and I
didn't have anymore that's sort of what
I'm talking about buffer but buffering
is you know the temporary transport of
data between two different sources
that's geeky so I think an easier way to
think about buffering and streaming is
what I'm doing right now I'm talking to
you and so I also lived in Spain for
three years now is primarily their
Kingdom I was probably there to go and
study and learn Spanish from scratch and
that went really well better than
expectations but always awful in my
foreign language I always wish I could
be better and in a conversation in
English you guys can talk at me Virgil
you almost a micro machines guy level
and I'm going to understand you i don't
really buffer any of that up you just
stream the words are you at me and i can
understand exactly you're saying however
a foreign language and like in Spanish
you've been having been there for three
years if somebody starts talking to me i
need to do one of two things they asked
me to ask them to slow down so I can
handle that stream of conversation or
someone will say something to me it's
good
take me a little while to catch up so i
have to buffer all the words they just
said in my head maybe I have to do a
little translation maybe I have to like
move around and then I understanding
well if you do that to me a lot of times
I'm gonna have like my CD burner like
this buffer underrun or overrun I'm
gonna lose the conversation so
conversations are pretty apt metaphor
for streaming data so when I'm talking
to you and if English is your first
language you're probably just receiving
all this and you're able to move on
right away if someone were to speak to
you in a foreign language any kind of
understood it might we have to buffer it
and we would take time doing that
understanding that so I'm open to that
explanation not being good but when i
say streaming I'd literally mean chunks
of data like words being spit out which
in your you guys are able to process as
sentences and buffering is the practice
of handling those and until you can
actually process them understand what
I'm saying okay you thought I was going
to talk about Jason though not foreign
language and how should I am in Spanish
presumably so what does that mean in
terms of JavaScript
this is really simple Jason structure
and if we wanted to know how many in
this list of Hall of Famers how many
Hall of Famers are there we would do
what I would do and this is a very
efficient way to do it i would offer
this whole response and then i would
Jason Knapp our sonic and then I would
do Hall of Famers length and we would
get to I can't do that until I have the
entire response and then I know that
there were two Hall of Famers I need to
do that with all of the Hall of Famers i
would have to virtually do the same
thing or split it up and make lots of
different requests I think that probably
serves to reason through that was
streaming however can approach that we
may take is actually to split this up
into two different chunks and I've
manipulated a little bit so that we can
tell that Kirby is a Hall of Famer and
George Brett or Hall of Famers but we
can shoot each of these lines eliminate
delimited delimited chunks of JSON at
the browser and we can parse each one of
them and the only thing that we really
need to keep track of is our count of
Hall of Famers so I could do that I wish
I would have looked this up but I don't
know how many Hall of Famers are but we
can do that for all of the Hall of
Famers and then we can get a comp versus
having to parse something that may have
you know if our memory like pro may not
allow me to have anybody know
the limit for memory for a tab whatever
that is you know if you go over that
you'll probably crash your tab and
you'll have to restart I say that right
I don't need to know but that's what's
going to happen okay so we're not
thinking about hall of famers I'm
wondering why is this matter and why do
we care about doing this so on the
client side like i said i right i'm
doing a lot of this streaming on the
server side and so the reason that it's
interesting for me to talk about it is
as you're passing a lot of streams
around when you can have that same
structure and pass it over the client it
gets super interesting and that's
selfish of me because you know it's nice
to just have these line delimited comma
delimited blobs of Jason just shoot them
right up to the browser and a lot of the
parcel so I don't have to sit there and
worry about these my Jason actually the
proper Jason not possible format but
outside being selfish a really nice
example in a place where I've work is
I've actually built the server-side
service that takes a ton of XML
responses parses through all of them and
then delivers to like Samsung
televisions and Roku Roku's I get to
leave their folk a really thin Jason
structure over to it and the reason we
had to do that is because those devices
themselves aren't able to parse through
this data so we have to come up with a
server-side solution how that relates is
an advantage of ice with the Streamy
mechanism in place could actually go and
request a lot of data off the wire maybe
within reason be able to parse through
to know
might not be possible if it had to take
the entire buffered chump the buffered
response wife's a little glasses per
second I'm probably being recorded
response and it crashed the television
or crash the cap in the television as it
were so that's why you want to do
something like this so I wanted to take
a little bit of a look how this might
work and not so much code as it is an
example and you're going to see here I'm
like I said I'm working with these
streams and I'm thinking in terms of
change it's not always clear cut and
obvious that you're going to want to do
this that you're going to want to go
through all this harnessing and set up
for you know something that's as simple
so quick 10 to the 3 is a thousand
objects I'm really I've slowed down the
server so it's actually shooting out a
thousand objects at a time so like this
is pretty instant and you can see the
object count go up and if I buffer it it
was I mean virtually the same thing so I
think this is translating pretty well so
if you're if you were doing some trivial
example like this I probably wouldn't
sit there and say oh we need to like
reorganize our entire data structure
into it things still aren't even that
interesting we have ten thousand objects
and like I said I've slow this down so
it's actually in this case dreamings a
little bit slower but I just did it so
you can kind of see how the doms getting
written two on each of on each of those
like data events I mean if we buffer ten
thousand objects it takes a little bit
what it takes a little while now a lot
of time is that server right there what
is true is the responsiveness of the
browser itself and I'm going to do that
one more time real quick is the
browser's writing right away because
it's receiving those
chunks of data that stream of data and
it's right to it in the in the buffered
example we sit there and we wait a
little bit and so the entire request is
complete and we're done and that's the
way that most you know I mean in a
trivial example you would just request
some Jason get it back and then operate
on that object by the way Firefox is
really good at this this example where
everything's like you can see it
happening in chrome doesn't it's not as
visual so I'll we can open up a chrome
and crash it with this next example
Firefox doesn't really crash at 100,000
either but here's a hundred thousand and
this is probably the best example
because this request does take a little
bit of time even if I'm not unrolling
the base of its of for loop that I just
say every 10,000 in a shootout what
would a thousand objects so this should
take 100 how long's are taking 100
milliseconds is 10 seconds to something
like that so this is streaming and then
if we buffer it again in chrome this
actually crashed the browser but and
you're seeing that the responses so this
gives us a couple of things it gives us
the efficiency of being able to handle a
little bit more data and again all new
years have taken literally wholesale the
data and putting in the Dom if we're
doing something even more simple and
just like passing it along we're doing
some little computation like counting
hall of famers that could actually be
more efficient than all this dom writing
and everything that's kind of hard to
demonstrate that
screen like that so and we're still
going here and again I do want to
reiterate that buffering doesn't
necessarily mean it's slow the server
itself is just taking a little bit of
time to send those out and so there it
is and you can kind of see but the
responsiveness I think is worth funding
on should we try that long it'll take
two
so
I think streams are good and I I him
like I said basically the primary way in
which i'm writing most of the projects
and the work I'm doing right now is
using streams as you get more into it as
you get more familiar with the options
that are out there there's the API
constrains you to a style of coding I
think that is really nice it provides
for some really nice testable abilities
as you know it's going to be readable
it's going to be writable it's gonna
admit certain events and then you've got
these nice kind of sort of depending on
how you look at it pure functions that
you can kind of like test in a really
really nice way you're constraining
yourself and so that for me has been
really really efficient especially in
the async browser no D whatever
environment where I've got a pretty good
grasp on how to organize the different
sections of my program as things are
going through that casting control along
passing data programs but i also want to
talk a little bit about like students
are kind of gnarly as well they're not I
don't think the greatest way all the
time and I and this happens to me where
you know if you're a hammer everything
looks like a nail and so I think when we
had the thousand objects you can see
that like having your server setup to
emit lime limited Jason probably
wouldn't be worth it in that case that
first example I showed another thing is
you know if someone's going to be
consuming your API publicly chances are
that they might not be thinking about
working with your data in a streaming
sense so maybe the internal team and the
people working depending on how the
structure set up the people working on
the front and app are into it and they
want to build a streaming application
and handle the data that way the
business services team says yeah let's
do that well next thing you know is like
you might have to have a separate API
for the public side that they didn't
they weren't in on that conversation and
now you I think maybe perhaps been not
the best Citizen of your own API of
entire everyone that consumes it has to
like thinking the streaming way which is
a little bit weird and you know there's
complexities that come up with doing
things in a streaming way that if you
just had a simple like buffered response
certainly I think can add to the like
level of debugging and two things you
need to look for so again all these
things i'm very happy to talk about if
there's questions but dominicks here
he's been working on the what we GE
stream spec for the browser so i didn't
really get into how i did all that but
they're working on expect that one day
you know will be implemented by the
browser's themselves I believe
say that right and and you know at that
time it'll be something it's a little
bit more consumable a little bit more
understandable so you definitely
recommend you check out the spec that
it's working there and Dominick's here
and well just a toggle with the setting
the excess to run though but I showed it
it really simple Jason example this OBO
j/s does a lot more offers a lot more
browser compatibility and we'll be able
to probably in terms of like handling
data and streaming data there that site
in that repository would do a really
good job of kind of continuing the
learning and continue to talk about
streams on the client side and then
finally browserify in terms of for
packaging up javascript and packaging up
kind of required node style or even node
modules themselves and running them in
the browser that ate the entire example
I just showed you I didn't really have
to do too much edification on students
on the client side my side am I on
because I was just able to browserify
everything up and it worked really great
so actually one of the things is nice
about giving talks as you learn a lot
and I was just did like browserify
output and it's
working so I guess that's it goes
without saying that if you're writing
note code or you're interested in how
you're gonna package your cook together
take a look at browserify compared with
some of the other tools that you may be
may be using it might be interesting i
was pleasantly surprised with with it
for this demo and some of the work that
i do as i said happy to talk and thank
you any questions are ya so there that
might not be like the question itself
question it doesn't make sense because
we're just talking about to like things
that we know about but if you can
imagine on a web socket I can send you
to me I can send out data events I can
handle those I could set up a streaming
API so to speak and handle each of those
data all of that data as it arrives
individually so extreme in it of itself
doesn't necessarily care where the data
is coming from so if that's over HTTP or
through a web socket as that data
arrives we would be able to hype it to
something else so like an example would
be like we talked about realplayer at
the beginning
quite literally there's an html5 API
that allow us to push video data or
audio data onto a media source and
there's these source buffers so we can
write our own HLS player for example and
you can do that over HTTP like HTTP Live
Streaming said or you could have your
own custom streaming video thing written
entirely in JavaScript using these html5
api's that was you know indifferent to
where the data was coming from and so
then once you have that data I push it
onto your screen which is this video
processor or this video like the street
city of Dalian the WebSocket won't
particular transport
yeah do you say web sockets are
transported and streams is just an API
for handling that idea that would be
gasps I think so forever ok everybody
hear that so Dominic said that he would
think of a stream as like as a type like
a promise and then you want to get
really gnarly the stream spectators were
on uses promises so it's like this going
on isn't I would know there's a fun yeah
yeah no I totally agree with that
because you could also make an argument
that streams are also another way of
handling asynchronous behavior and kid
compared compete heads on with promises
and I'm not even knew that that was all
to lose it but you could you could do so
but arguments happen to the ball rack
yeah so following on that does kind of
an earlier question your example was
using am I correct and yes we're using
HTTP and transfer
the one request you are writing to the
tcp on these reconnection letting a
thousand lines big drops now I'm
necessarily a thousand lines of data the
packet could have I mean where'd of that
wherever that new line separator was
happening okay yeah i was doing where
they trying to go HTTP connection if I
were looking at our blood flow to the
developer tools I would see one you know
one who requested the network tab yeah
that I would have been okay how do we
get this up here
this is not it's the same thing so
here's this Jamie so it's just like
Texas that's one requirement we did
wonderful just casa de la MOLLE of
course there's nothing special going on
no it's a that gives the same request
and with xhr to and depending on the
browser you can check what how much data
is sitting there on like whole advanced
or so actually I'm not studying to the
back to the server so direction is my
buttercream it's a lot cheaper whoops I
get from my consumer I could use this as
it rest request in your idea
yeah yeah you can keep it like I said
for better or worse for better or worse
absolutely put you cook yeah absolutely
yeah i mean i think the WebSocket
transport you could do i mean you have
the exact same thing happening when
we're website and push a bunch of data
and listen for the same i'm not doing a
lot of web sockets work but i think that
this room is this like yeah there we go
now we've got the bar conversation maybe
this is the progress of the bed like
that's getting in the day how is he
getting the data i think you actually
again I was just able to like browserify
this but you're able to in anyone can
correct went wrong look at the response
periodically and pull whatever data is
on it and it's like that can become to
chunk so you could never do that and you
can just buffer up the whole thing but
if you look on the ready state i think
as that changes resident three
if you don't get the joke actually
anything else before i relinquish I just
understood one thing there are libraries
or pervasive JSON parsing true so you
can also get like the Hall of Famer
example you could just take that as if
it were raw text and parse back through
as it comes most definitely
your examples using X hrs or gathered it
up go check our little bit right yep
it's all the same exact 12 yeah it's all
the same exact HTTP requests yeah I'm
the client when i get everything i'm
actually putting it back together as
like normal jason i think so anyway
joining comment cool